there was this suspense that built
because the actual tweets,
you had no control over when you would read them.
They were coming at a pretty regular clip,
but as the story was building,
normally, as a reader, you control how fast you move through a text,
but in this case, The New Yorker did,
and they were sending you bit by bit by bit,
and you had this suspense of waiting for the next line.
Another great example of fiction
and the short story on Twitter,
Elliott Holt is an author who wrote a story called "Evidence."
It began with this tweet: "On November 28
at 10:13 p.m.,
a woman identified as Miranda Brown,
44, of Brooklyn, fell to her death
from the roof of a Manhattan hotel."
It begins in Elliott's voice,
but then Elliott's voice recedes,
and we hear the voices of Elsa, Margot and Simon,
characters that Elliott created on Twitter
specifically to tell this story,
a story from multiple perspectives
leading up to this moment at 10:13 p.m.
when this woman falls to her death.
These three characters brought an authentic vision
from multiple perspectives.
One reviewer called Elliott's story
"Twitter fiction done right," because she did.
She captured that voice
and she had multiple characters and it happened in real time.
Interestingly, though, it wasn't just
Twitter as a distribution mechanism.
It was also Twitter as a production mechanism.
Elliott told me later
she wrote the whole thing with her thumbs.
She laid on the couch and just went back and forth
between different characters
tweeting out each line, line by line.
I think that this kind of spontaneous creation
of what was coming out of the characters' voices
really lent an authenticity to the characters themselves,
but also to this format that she had created
of multiple perspectives in a single story on Twitter.
As you begin to play with flexible identity online,
it gets even more interesting
as you start to interact with the real world.
Things like Invisible Obama
or the famous "binders full of women"
that came up during the 2012 election cycle,
or even the fan fiction universe of "West Wing" Twitter
in which you have all of these accounts
for every single one of the characters in "The West Wing,"
including the bird that taps at Josh Lyman's window
in one single episode. (Laughter)
All of these are rapid iterations on a theme.
They are creative people experimenting
with the bounds of what is possible in this medium.
You look at something like "West Wing" Twitter,
in which you have these fictional characters
that engage with the real world.
They comment on politics,
they cry out against the evils of Congress.
Keep in mind, they're all Democrats.
And they engage with the real world.
They respond to it.
So once you take flexible identity,
anonymity, engagement with the real world,
and you move beyond simple homage or parody
and you put these tools to work in telling a story,
that's when things get really interesting.
So during the Chicago mayoral election
there was a parody account.
It was Mayor Emanuel.
It gave you everything you wanted from Rahm Emanuel,
particularly in the expletive department.
This foul-mouthed account
followed the daily activities of the race,
providing commentary as it went.
It followed all of the natural tropes
of a good, solid Twitter parody account,
but then started to get weird.
And as it progressed, it moved from this commentary
to a multi-week, real-time science fiction epic
in which your protagonist, Rahm Emanuel,
engages in multi-dimensional travel on election day,
which is -- it didn't actually happen.
I double checked the newspapers.
And then, very interestingly, it came to an end.
This is something that doesn't usually happen
with a Twitter parody account.
It ended, a true narrative conclusion.
And so the author, Dan Sinker, who was a journalist,
who was completely anonymous this whole time,
I think Dan -- it made a lot of sense for him
to turn this into a book,
because it was a narrative format in the end,
and I think that turning it into a book
is representative of this idea that he had created something new
that needed to be translated into previous formats.
One of my favorite examples
of something that's happening on Twitter right now,
actually, is the very absurdist Crimer Show.
Crimer Show tells the story
of a supercriminal and a hapless detective
that face off in this exceptionally strange lingo,
with all of the tropes of a television show.
Crimer Show's creator has said that
it is a parody of a popular type of show in the U.K.,
but, man, is it weird.
And there are all these times where Crimer,
the supercriminal, does all of these TV things.
He's always taking off his sunglasses
or turning to the camera,
but these things just happen in text.
I think borrowing all of these tropes from television
and additionally presenting each Crimer Show
as an episode, spelled E-P-P-A-S-O-D, "eppasod,"
presenting them as episodes
really, it creates something new.
There is a new "eppasod" of Crimer Show
on Twitter pretty much every day,
and they're archived that way.
And I think this is an interesting experiment in format.
Something totally new has been created here
out of parodying something on television.
I think in nonfiction real-time storytelling,
there are a lot of really excellent examples as well.
RealTimeWWII is an account
that documents what was happening on this day 60 years ago
in exceptional detail, as if
you were reading the news reports from that day.
And the author Teju Cole has done
a lot of experimentation with putting a literary twist
on events of the news.
In this particular case, he's talking about drone strikes.
I think that in both of these examples,
you're beginning to see ways in which
people are telling stories with nonfiction content
that can be built into new types
of fictional storytelling.
So with real-time storytelling,
blurring the lines between fact and fiction,
the real world and the digital world,
flexible identity, anonymity,
these are all tools that we have accessible to us,
and I think that they're just the building blocks.
They are the bits that we use
to create the structures, the frames,
that then become our settlements on this
wide open frontier for creative experimentation.
Thank you.
(Applause)